be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so with models release or the first
teaser trailer for the Iron Fist Netflix
series what I want to do here is have an
explanation about Danny Rand and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of all
this you'll have a better understanding
of his character as well as some idea of
what to expect going forward into the
release of his Netflix series so iron
fist was created by Roy Thomas and Gil
Kane and made his debut appearance and
Marvel premiere issue number 15 in May
of 1974 and a note written by Roy
colonists in the same issue the
inspiration for iron fist creation was
twofold
the first inspiration for the character
came from Roy Thomas's affinity with
martial arts movies which had become
extremely popular in the early 1970s and
in fact the name iron fist was taken
directly from a line in one of the
movies that Roy Thomas had watched the
other inspiration for iron fist came in
the form of a golden age character
called the amazing man which was created
by Bill Everett in 1939 and starred in
his own solo series published by Centaur
publications from 1939 until 1942 now in
the original issue of the series the
amazing man's influence is clear an iron
fist first appearance which also
provides his origin story what we're
told is that Danny Rand is a
nine-year-old boy on an expedition in
the Himalayan mountains with his parents
Wendel and Heather Rand as well as his
father's friend and business partner
Harold Meacham where window land was
determined to find the mythical city of
Kunlun which Chinese legend held was
home to the Immortals during the climb
Windell slips and his friend Harold
betrays him stomping his hand and
causing him to fall to his death
responding to the shocked expressions of
Windows wife and Danny Meechum explains
that his actor betrayal was motivated by
his desire to take control of the
company for himself as well as declare
his love for Windows wife Heather
however after Heather reviews his
advances Meechum leaves her and Danny to
fend for themselves in the harsh
conditions of the Himalayas and after
Heather and Danny attempt to make their
way out of the mountains to safety the
two are pursued by a pack of wolves
with Heather sacrificing her life by
throwing herself into the pack in order
to give - any time to get away and so
watching his mother being consumed by
the wolves Danny finds himself rescued
by a group of men who claim to be from
the city of Kunlun from here we pick up
with Danny as he meets a man named UT
who operates as a leader of Kunlun and
expresses his condolences over the loss
of Danny's parents and offers to fulfill
any request and he may have taking
advantage of the
Trinity Danny quickly responds that what
he wants most is revenge which UT says
he cannot give him instead UT takes
Danny to Lake [ __ ] the Thunderer to be
trained in martial arts in hopes that
the training will overcome the hatred
Danny harbors towards Meechum and so
over the next several years Danny is
trained within the city of Kunlun as an
apprentice to Leigh [ __ ] becoming his
most promised student and at the age of
sixteen is able to steal a crown of food
hits the king of the vipers however
where Danny walks away from the training
session feeling that his accomplishment
is empty after several more training
sessions he speaks with UT who offers
Danny the opportunity to gain the power
of the iron fist which will require him
to defeat the dragon shallow the undying
accepting the task Danny is able to
subdue the dragon by covering the scar
through which the dragon's heart was
removed and in doing so receives the
magical properties of the dragon giving
Danny immortality using his temporary
inability to die Danny located rock his
heart inside the cavern and plunges his
hands into the molten heart repeatedly
allowing Danny to focus all of his
energy into his hands and make them as
hard as iron now from here the story
fast forwards one month where Danny is
taken before UT and the Dragon Kings to
endure a trial by combat to prove his
worthiness to become one of the
Immortals after defeating all the
enemies set before him Danny's brought
before the tree of immortality by UT and
offered a difficult decision Danny can
either gain immortality and live forever
or he can return to the world in which
he came from which is only possible once
every decade that happens to occur on
the very next day announcing his
intention to return to this world and
seek revenge on Meechum and never to
dissuade Danny from his quest UT reveals
the Danish father Wendell was also UT's
brother
however despite his shock at this
revelation Danny does not allow the
information to deter him and he leaves
Kunlun to seek out Meechum in New York
City and so as the origin story begins
to wrap up Iron Fist makes his way to
meet some industries in New York and
finds himself face to face with a man
responsible for the death of his parents
confronted with his chance to finally
slay Meacham where iron fist initially
box at the revelation that Meacham is
now confined to a wheelchair having lost
his legs to amputation due to frostbite
that he suffered after getting lost in
the Himalayas Iron Fist finds himself
unable to feel anything but pity for
Meacham and leaves without harming him
despite Meacham's pleased that he's
ready to meet death now because the
popularity of martial
content was running strong in the early
to mid-1970s following this initial
story iron fists received his own solo
series written by Chris Claremont and
drawn by John Byrne in November of 1975
while the duo Claremont and Byrne was
used
owing to their popularity on the x-men
line this series also featured stories
with cameos by some of Marvel's most
popular heroes including Iron Man
Captain America and the x-men and also
featured the debut of Sabretooth in
issue number 14 however because martial
arts craze was dying out leading to a
drop in sales of the Iron Fist title
instead of throwing a series onto the
chopping block Marvel looked to the
struggling title of Luke Cage as a way
to combine the two characters into a
team-up series to this end and with
Claremont and John Byrne remaining on
board to launch the title Luke cages
Power Man series was renamed to Power
Man and Iron Fist and the comic
numbering was continued with issue
number 50 coming out of a two-part story
which began in each character's solo
series and culminated in their first
issue of the team-up when Luke Cage
breaks into Danny rands home looking for
the information broker misty Knight his
actions find him coming face to face
with Colleen wing the girlfriend of
Danny Rand where iron fists and Misty
night come to her aid
but her overpowered by Luke Cage is
super strike in bulletproof skin in the
middle of the scuffle and while on the
verge of killing Danny Luke Cage
explains that the reason he had broken
in was that he been blackmailed by the
villain known as Bushmaster who would
instructed cage to kidnap Missy in
exchange for Claire in cages name where
this story was used as a jumping off
platform for the he web series if you're
interested in learning more about Power
Man and Iron Fist I urge you to watch my
video on Luke Cage explained which
covers the progression of the series in
detail suffice it to say were the
writing styles of Mary Jo Duffy and curb
music took a more communica proach which
came in opposition to Marvel taking
their lineup in the direction of darker
and grittier stories
following the death of when Stacy in
1971 after the removal of both Joe Duffy
and Kurt Busiek from the writing
positions editor-in-chief Joe shooter
plays Christopher crease on the title as
a series final writer during which time
Iron Fist was killed off starting in
issue number 117 iron fist and Power Man
had befriended and mentored a young boy
named Bobby Wright who had the power to
transform into a superhero called
Captain hero however Danny and Luke also
discovered that Bobby's terminally ill
with cancer and so while iron fists even
uses mystical abilities to drain his own
life force to keep body alive for a
period of time and
hank pym could create a set of mega
bands based on pre technology which he
believed would cure volume one of
Marvel's most controversial moments came
as Bobby lies asleep in the hospital
with iron fists at his side and Luke
Cage waiting in the hallway waking up in
the middle of the night in a great deal
of pain
Bobby attempts to wake up iron fist but
is so hysterical that he begins punching
him eventually punching him through a
wall killing him in the process and so
as a result and with Luke Cage coming
into the room to see what had happened
Luke Cage is actually blamed for the
murder is Bobby right disappears and
eventually goes into hiding now
something that I want to do here is
actually want to point out the real-life
reason behind the death of Danny ran and
the Power Man and Iron Fist comics with
issue number 125 covered in a personal
blog post from 2000 on his own website
fighter Christopher priest had stated
that the decision to kill iron fist
did not come from him and instead came
from an assistant of the titles editor
Dennis O'Neil according to the post
O'Neill and the rest of the team were
angry over the series cancellation owing
to the pact that with a title receiving
universal acclaim and selling over
100,000 units each month the eventual
decline in sales did not come from the
writing of the series and instead came
from almost decision to shift the series
from bi-weekly to monthly and an effort
to make room for new titles as a result
and operating out of anger O'Neil took
the advice of his assistant to kill iron
fist and pin the murder on Luke Cage in
the host that the Act would turn fans
off to marvel in the Luke Cage character
as a whole and so following this Danny
Rand remained absent from Marvel Comics
until November of 1990 when he was
seemingly resurrected by name of the
Submariner in issue number 8 of his own
solo series written and drawn by John
Byrne during this story it was revealed
that the resurrected Danny Rand was
actually the super scroll in disguise
however when this initially seemed
relatively simple the resurrection of
Danny Rand was anything but in issue
number 24 of the Namor Submariner series
it was also revealed the super scroll
had been resurrected from the radiation
belts around earth by master cog an evil
sorcerer from Kunlun who had battled
with iron fists and car man in the past
what we're told is that master Codd had
offered to cure super scroll of the
Leukemia he had contracted in exchange
for help in defeating iron fist and with
a super scroll agrees and begins to use
his shape-shifting abilities to take on
the forms of body right captain hero and
Tyrone King a police officer introduced
in the Power Man and Iron Fist series
with whom misty Knight
relationship with it was revealed by
virtue of a retcon that super scroll and
not Bobby Wright had kill iron fist in
addition to this the writing of John
Byrne also provided the retcon that iron
fist himself had not died an issue
number 125 a Power Man and Iron Fist and
instead it had been a duplicate grown by
the hill 3 a plant race that had been
longtime enemies of Kunlun instead the
real Danny Rand had been held in stasis
after being captured by the hill 3
sometime prior to his supposed death
and so after misty Knight and Colleen
wing learned that the real Danny Rand is
alive they travel with name of the
Submariner to Kunlun and free Danny from
his stasis ending his over 4-year
absences for Marvel Comics now following
this resurrection iron fist would regain
control of his father's company but
would eventually sell it to Namor and
use the money to assemble a new Heroes
for Hire team with Luke Cage as well as
an expanded roster that included
Hercules she-hulk
ant-man Scott Lang and Black Knight in
addition to this name Warren would
eventually dissolve his Oracle
Corporation which owned Heroes for Hire
and eventually the team disbanded now
fast forwarding Invictus 2006 the Civil
War event Danny ran adopts a moniker in
costume of daredevil after daredevil
secret identity of Matt Murdock is made
public in order to trick the public and
the media into thinking that Matt
Murdock was not daredevil by letting
them be seen together where Danny ran
still under the daredevil mask also
joins Captain America's
anti-registration Secret Avengers team
he's eventually captured by Iron Fist
co-registration forces and imprison in
the negative zone for a period of time a
furthermore following Civil War iron
fists joined the New Avengers team in
issue number 27 written by Brian Michael
Bendis we reunites with Luke Cage for
the first time following the conclusion
of their Power Man and Iron Fist series
during Danny Rams time on the New
Avengers he purchases an apartment
building for the team to use as her
headquarters but eventually leaves the
team following the relocation of their
headquarters to Captain America's home
in New Avengers number 51
citing personal business that he has to
take care of but enclose a team that
he'll be available to help out should
they need him it's also during this
period that we see iron fists get his
first solo ongoing series since the
cancellation of his 1970 series prior to
his first team up with Power Man
in November of 2006 Marvel launched the
immortal iron fist
written jointly by Ed Brubaker and Matt
Fraction with art by David Asia and
travel
forming the series focus on the lineage
of the iron fist and introduces
characters that held the title prior to
Danny Rand and in the first arc of the
series Jaime's predecessor Orson Randall
a veteran of the First World War who
still uses the abilities and immortality
of the iron fist is also scarred by his
time in combat and becomes a reclusive
drug addict on the run from Hydra and
the steel serpent whoreson finds Danny
and tells him that he trained his father
many years ago and also gives him the
book of the iron fist in tells Danny
that he'll need the book in order to get
ready for the tournament of the heavenly
Cities now will Randall dies soon after
being attacked by the steel serpent with
his final act he surrenders the Chi that
remains in his body to Danny which
allows iron fist to stay in turn to toe
with the steel serpent battling him to a
draw before being beckoned by UT his
previous mentor in Kunlun from here iron
fist is forced into a tournament where
he must battle the champions of the
other seven capital cities of heaven
during which time the tournament decides
which city will be able to appear on
earth once each decade where Danny is
defeated in the first round of the
tournament he discovers two the leaders
of each of the seven cities had secretly
built portals to earth without the
knowledge of the other people and the
deception of the current UT promised
iron fists two joined forces with ley
kun and the daughter of Orson Randall to
overthrow the current regime of Kunlun
now where Ed Brubaker would leave the
immortal iron fists following issue
number fourteen leaving Matt Fraction to
ride to issues on his own before handing
the writing duties over to Dwayne's
porzinski starting with issue number 17
in August of 2008 the book would receive
critical acclaim being nominated for a
2008 Eisner Award for Best new series
however the immortal Iron Fist series
was canceled with issue number 27 now
following the cancellation of the
immortal iron fist Danny ran joins
forces with the New Avengers team once
again were uniting with Luke Cage during
this time he also proposes to misty
Knight who accepts and informs Danny the
she's pregnant with his child in
addition to this and after the pregnancy
was revealed to be false the two began
living separately although they
continued to be romantically involved in
addition to this iron fist joins a
reassemble defenders team consisting of
Doctor Strange
Silver Surfer Namor and red she-hulk and
Matt fractions 2011 Defender Series
which only ran for 12 issues and was
actually retconned within its own pages
so that the defenders reunion never
happened as Doctor Strange changes the
past to avoid the end of the universe
brought about by the defenders actions
and so in the years leading up to the
start of Secret Wars and the launch of
all different Marvel Iron Fist was once
again given a solo series in 2014 with
care Andrews Iron Fist the living weapon
which ran for 12 issues before being
cancelled in May of 2015 now whether or
not Iron Fist will get his own solo
series following the launch of all-new
all-different marvel is unknown but what
we do know is that Marvel is currently
launching a Power Man and Iron Fist
team-up series which goes back to the
roots of the original Power Man and Iron
Fist series as it was written by Mary Jo
Duffy Chris Claremont and Kurt Busiek
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it and I'll catch you guys
later peace